FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP TURNING
THE TABLES ON THE MEDIA AS
REPUBLICANS RAMP UP THE PRESSURE
TO RELEASE MORE MATERIALS FROM
THE UNPRECEDENTED FBI RAID ON
HIS HOME, THE PRESS GOING INTO
FULL RUSSIAGATE MODE ALL TRYING
TO DISPUTE TRUMP'S TRAIN THAT
THE BUREAU SEIZED HIS PASSPORTS.
CBS ANCHOR NORAH O'DONNELL
TWEETING "ACCORDING TO A DOJ
OFFICIAL, THE FBI IS NOT IN
POSSESSION OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PASSPORTS,
TRUMPET ACCUSE THE FBI OF
STEALING IT, THREE PASSPORTS
DURING THE SEARCH OF HIS
MAR-A-LAGO HOME.
THE ORANGEMEN IS FORCED TO
CORRECT THE RECORD WITH HIS
SPOKESMAN POSTING THE EMAIL THAT
BACKS HIM UP, PROVING THE AGENCY
REMOVED HIS TRAVEL DOCUMENTS
FROM MAR-A-LAGO AND WOULD BE
RETURNING THEM.
MEDIA IS ALSO RAMPING UP THEIR
GOOD VERSUS EVIL GAME.
>> AND I WOULD SAY TO OUR
FRIENDS WHO ARE WATCHING US
TODAY, VOTE AS IF YOUR LIFE
DEPENDS ON IT, IF KEVIN
McCARTHY THREATENED THE
POSSIBLE NEXT SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, THREATENED AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND SAYS,
YOU'D BETTER LAY OFF TRUMP OR
ELSE --
>> ARE WE GOING TO SURVIVE THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THE HOPEFUL PART OF THIS IS THAT
AMERICA DOES HAVE RESILIENCE AND
WE DO GET OVER MOMENTS LIKE
THIS.
>> AND REMEMBER HOW THIS RAID
WAS URGENTLY NEEDED TO PROTECT
NATIONAL SECURITY?
TURNS OUT MERRICK GARLAND SAT ON
HIS BUTT AND WAITED WEEKS TO PUT
THE SEARCH WARRANTS.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW THE
UNDERLYING EVIDENCE THAT WAS
USED TO JUSTIFY AGENTS GOING
THROUGH MELANIA'S WARDROBE.
RIGHT NOW THE DOJ RECOMMENDS TO
KEEP THAT SEALED.
BUT I JUDGE SET A THURSDAY
HEARING TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
PUBLIC GETS TO SEE IT OR NOT TO
PICK SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS
TRANSPARENCY NOW.
>> WE NEED THE AFFIDAVIT.
SHOW YOUR CARDS.
MERRICK GARLAND CAN'T HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS.
WITHOUT TELLING US WHY IT WAS
NECESSARY WITHOUT THE AFFIDAVIT,
WE ARE FLYING BLIND IN THE DARK,
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
DO -- GOING THROUGH TOO MUCH
PAIN, TOO MUCH HEARTACHE, ON
THIS EFFORT TO DESTROY
DONALD TRUMP.
>> JUDGE, WELCOME BACK TO.
YOU WERE MISSED.
>> REALLY?
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I THINK.
>> GOING TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> LET'S REMEMBER WHO IS
CONDUCTING THIS HEARING ON
THURSDAY, THE SAME JUDGE WHO
SIGNED THE WARRANT, OKAY?
SO YOU'VE GOT THIS JUDGE WHO
SIGNED A WARRANT THAT APPARENTLY
WAS MESSED UP FROM THE GET-GO,
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY, IF IT
WERE A SEARCH WARRANT AND THEY
MADE A DECISION TO GO BEYOND
WITH A COURT ORDER, THEY HAD TO
BE SOME EXIGENT CIRCUMSTANCES,
HAD TO BE SOME EMERGENCY, THEN
WE FIND OUT THAT MERRICK GARLAND
WAITED WEEKS BEFORE HE ACTUALLY
MADE A FINAL DECISION ON THAT,
THEN WE FIND OUT THAT EVEN
BEFORE THEN, IN JUNE, THE
PRESIDENT WAS COOPERATING WITH
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES PEOPLE,
SENT HIM A THANK YOU NOTE FOR
COOPERATING, SO WITH THIS
HEARING, THE JUDGE HAS TO
DECIDE, LOOK, WE'VE GOT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC'S INTEREST IN
THIS, BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS SAYING, NO, WE DON'T
WANT YOU TO RELEASE THIS
AFFIDAVIT, THE BASIS FOR THE
WARRANT, BECAUSE WE THINK IT
WILL COMPROMISE WHATEVER
INVESTIGATION WE ARE DOING, THAT
IT WILL CAUSE HARM, AND THAT IT
DOESN'T SERVE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST.
THERE IS SENSITIVE INFORMATION,
A ROAD MAP TO WHERE WE ARE
GOING, BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, IN
MY 30 YEARS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT,
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF A
DEFENDANT -- AND REMEMBER, THIS
IS A CRIMINAL WARRANT BASED ON A
STATUTE THAT IS NOT A CRIMINAL
STATUTE, THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
RECORD, AND SO WHAT HE IS
SAYING -- THE PRESIDENT SAYING,
RELEASE IT, I DON'T SEE WHAT IT
SAYS, I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
IT SAYS.
SO THIS JUDGE IS IN A BOX.
THE JUDGE HAS TO SAY, WAIT A
MINUTE, WE'VE GOT THE DEFENDANT
HIMSELF, THE WANNABE DEFENDANT,
SAYING, LET IT ALL OUT, THE
JUDGE THEN HAS TO DECIDE, WAS IT
A WHOLESALE FISHING EXPEDITION?
NOW WE HAVE AMERICANS TUNED INTO
THIS.
THEY TOOK PASSPORTS.
THE MEDIA, BASED ON NORA
O'DONNELL SAYING, OH, THEY
DIDN'T SAY IT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
LIKE, WE GOT A WARRANT,
LEGITIMATE WARRANT FROM THE FISA
COURT.
BUT NO WORRIES, JUSTICE IS STILL
GOOD WITH THE FBI, IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT, THEN YOU GOT A
PROBLEM.
IN THE END, THIS JUDGE, I THINK,
IS GOING TO MAKE A DECISION THAT
IT'S GOT TO BE RELEASED, THAT
THEY WILL ONLY REJECT CERTAIN
PARTS OF IT, -- REDACT CERTAIN
PARTS OF IT, I THINK THERE IS
EGG ON THE FACE.
>> ENOUGH TO MAKE A 10-EGG
OMELETTE, DANA.
DIDN'T EVEN REALIZE WERE GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE UP -- HOW DO YOU
SAY HIS NAME?
THIS IS THE SAME GUY THAT
TREATED THE ROSENBERGS -- THEY
SOLD SECRETS TO MOSCOW AND THEY
WERE EXECUTED, THE INFERENCE
BEING THAT TRUMP WOULD BE
EXECUTED TOO.
WHAT RIGHTS DOES HE HAVE?
>> A LOT OF THE HISTORIANS HAVE
BEEN CONCERNED FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS NOW ABOUT NORMS AND
INSTITUTIONS, AND THE PROTECTION
OF THE CONSTITUTION, ET CETERA,
I WAS JUST THINKING ABOUT --
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING, JUDGE,
THE DEFENDANT -- IT'S NOT EVEN
REALLY A DEFENDANT YET, RIGHT?
AND WE STILL BELIEVE IN INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY, THAT'S IN
THE CONSTITUTION, AT THIS POINT,
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW HE COULD
SAY THE NORMS OF THE COUNTRY ARE
AT RISK, BUT ALSO TO EAT
SOMETHING THAT BASICALLY SAYS,
DONALD TRUMP IS GUILTY OF
SELLING SECRETS TO THE RUSSIANS.
I DO WISH, ON THE MEDIA SIDE OF
THINGS, I KNOW YOU WANT TO BE
FIRST, BUT IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO BE RIGHT.
AND THE WHOLE PASSPORT THING
JUST STIRRED THE POT EVEN
FURTHER.
>> SAME WITH THE NUKE STUFF, IT
JUST SOUNDS SO MUCH LIKE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THE OTHER THING, WHY DID IT GO
IN MELANIA'S CLOSET, THERE COULD
BE A REALLY SIMPLE ANSWER.
MAYBE THAT'S WHERE THE SAFE WAS.
WHY AREN'T THEY SAYING THAT.
>> IT'S WAY TOO LOW-HANGING
FRUIT, ELABORATE EVENING GOWNS
NOW, BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED AT
MAR-A-LAGO, POLITICALLY ACTIVE
CHARGED RATE HAVE, THINKS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEING
PERSECUTED UNFAIRLY ONCE AGAIN,
THE OTHER COUNTRY WOULD JUST
ASSUME HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
EXECUTED FOR TREASON.
WHY WOULD THE FBI -- WHY WOULD
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TAKE
STEPS TO PUT US IN THIS POSITION
TODAY?
IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT TRUMP
DESERVES SPECIAL TREATMENT.
I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT THAT
THOSE DOCUMENTS PROBABLY BELONG
TO THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT,
THEY NEEDED TO FIND THEIR WAY
BACK THERE, IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY
ARE NEGOTIATING ON HOW TO KEEP
THOSE THINGS SAFE.
SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE IN
AGREEMENT, THEN THEY SAID,
BECAUSE OF AN FBI SOURCE AND
SURVEILLANCE, THEY HAVE REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS
WEREN'T AS SECURE AS THEY WANTED
THEM TO BE.
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK, TRUMP
DOESN'T DESERVE SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
DESERVE TO BE THROWN INTO
ANOTHER POLARIZING SITUATION AND
HAVE ARGUMENTS WHERE HE COULD BE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS WHERE WE SIT
AROUND AND SAY, OH, MY GOD,
GOING AFTER TRUMP YET AGAIN,
TRUMP TRYING TO SELL OUR NUCLEAR
SECRETS TO THE SOVIETS.
I DON'T BELIEVE EITHER ONE OF
THOSE ARE WHOLESALE TRUE, BUT
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF REASON FOR
PEOPLE TO SIT AROUND TO MAKE
THOSE ARGUMENTS NOW BECAUSE OF
THIS, IN MY OPINION.
>> YOU KNOW, RICHARD, HAPPENED
TO ME, A POORLY MADE.
OH, AND FALLS APART WHEN YOU'RE
DRIVING.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE, THIS NARRATIVE
IS FALLING APART AS THE MEDIA
DRIVES IT AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS BESIDES
AGREEING WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH ME?
>> I DON'T EAT A BURRITO WHILE
I'M DRIVING.
DO YOU REALLY?
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE SHOWING IT
IN THE B BLOCK.
>> REALLY.
A COUPLE OF THINGS HERE, LISTEN,
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF MEDIA
SPECULATION ON ALL SIDES, RIGHT?
BOTH ON THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT,
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO SPECULATE,
IN MELANIA'S CLOSET, NOT IN
MELANIA'S CLOSET, WHAT IS
CLASSIFIED OR CONFIDENTIAL
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE RATED, WILL
FIND OUT TOMORROW, THE 18TH,
WHEN THE JUDGE HAS ITS HEARING.
I THINK WE SHOULD RELEASE THE
AFFIDAVIT, NORMALLY JUDGES DON'T
DO THAT BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
TO TARNISH REPUTATIONS, LET'S
RELEASE AND LET'S GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT, BUT WITH THAT
BEING SAID, I THINK THERE IS FAR
TOO MUCH SPECULATION, PEOPLE GO,
THIS IS THE FOLKS, BUT THINK
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF CLEARANCE
THAT THIS WARRANT HAS BUILT,
APPOINTED MIKE CHRISTOPHER WRAY
APPOINTED, ALSO POINTED BY --
ALSO SIGNED UP BY
MERRICK GARLAND.
HE HAS DECADES THE FEDERAL
BENCH.
PROGRESSIVES HAVE KNOCKED
MERRICK GARLAND FOR BEING TOO
SLOW, BUT THAT IS WHAT JUDGES
DO, THEY ARE JUDICIOUS.
ON TOP OF THAT COMMITMENT TO A
FEDERAL JUDGE, THE JUDGE SAID,
BASED ON THE INFORMATION, REPORT
THAT IT IS VERY LIKELY THAT THE
PERSON WITH THIS EVIDENCE OF
SOMEBODY FROM THE SECURITY
DETAIL, SAW THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, THEY HAVE THE
MANDATORY ABILITY, AND THEY
REPORTED THAT THEY SAW THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE PUTTING YOUR
LIFE IN THE HANDS OF SOMEONE
THAT WANTS TO WRITE YOU OUT LIKE
THAT?
>> IF MERRICK GARLAND IS SO
JUDICIOUS, HOW COME HE CALLED --
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS AND 60 FBI
ON THEM?
I HAVE TROUBLE WITH THAT.
>> ME TOO.
MELANIA'S CLOSET SOUNDS LIKE A
SIT COME ON HALLMARK.
>>